et le prix de la meilleure caméra de ses
premiers explique mans encore howard aux
caméras of machin eh bien il est décerné
à et salue les gens derrière l'écran ça
fait plaisir de vous retrouver une
nouvelle fois sur cette chaîne pour une
nouvelle vidéo est aujourd'hui je vais
répondre à la question qu'on me pose
tout le temps sur les réseaux sociaux
surtout sur un stade c'est qu'elle est
la meilleure caméra et puis je aller un
petit peu plus loin quelle est la
meilleure caméra de 2020 ce que 2020 ça
a été une année quand même assez pourri
on est d'accord mais il s'est passé
quand même des choses au niveau des
sorties de caméras qui sont assez ou
entre le canon eos r5 le sony à 7 est
roi le zi6 de la redd komodo l'efs x6
fin j'en passe et des meilleurs vraiment
il s'est passé plein de choses et ça
vous a visiblement beaucoup questionné
pour l'achat de matériel renouvellement
de votre matériel donc dans cette vidéo
on va résoudre votre problème mais
surtout restez bien jusqu'à la fin parce
que ben comme toujours un c'est un
développement construit
la réponse c'est à la fin et la réponse
ne veut rien dire c'est en début fin
voilà vous avez compris restez bien
jusqu'à la fin et puis bien entendu si
vous aimez tout ce qui est caméra
montage tournage tout ça cliquez sur le
petit bouton s'abonner qui se situe
juste en dessous de cette vidéo et
surtout qu'en plus je pense que vous
allez pas vous attendre forcément à la
réponse que je vais vous donner alors je
vais pas vous faire une liste de
fichiers comparer lequel fait de la
quête de 10 bits de l'habitat de machin
non ce que je vais faire c'est vous
donnez des critères des critères qui
vont pouvoir vous aider dans votre choix
et vous allez voir que c'est pas si
compliqué le premier critère qui pour
moi est important c'est l'ergonomie
l'ergonomie c'est la façon dont l'outil
va s'accorder avec vous la façon dont
vous allez de trouver plus ou moins
simples la façon dont vous allez
interagir avec soi que ça soit
complètement un prolongement
vous êtes-vous d'oublier complètement et
vous faites votre truc soit que ce soit
quelque chose qui soit compliqué avec
des menus complexes etc
et là je vais vous faire une première
analogie qui risque d'y en avoir
quelques unes mais vous allez voir c'est
pour vous faire comprendre les choses
dire qu'une caméra une meilleure
ergonomie qu'une autre à mon sens c'est
quelque chose qui ne veut rien dire je
vous explique pourquoi
si je dis que ma paire de pompes de
sport ne fait pas vraiment de sport mais
on imagine que je fasse du sport
si je dis que ma paire de pompes de
sport elle a la meilleure ergonomie elle
est hyper confortable elle ne va très
très bien moi qui chausse du 42
si je vais dire ça à un mec qui fait du
basket professionnel et qui mesure 2 m
20 ma paire de pompes va forcément pas
avoir une bonne ergonomie pour lui
puisque il est foutu différemment il ad
beaucoup plus grands pieds il va lui
falloir quelque chose d'autre et ça ne
va absolument pas lui convenir en termes
d'ergonomie de caméras c'est la même
chose on parle souvent des menus qui
sont plus ou moins complexes selon les
marques on dit souvent que les menus
sony sont hyper complexe pas du tout
pratique etc
mais moi par exemple mon premier
appareil photo c'était un aps c sony via
x années et en fait j'ai commencé avec
ses menus là donc ils me paraissent
totalement logique quand j'entends des
gens qui disent c'est pas du tout
ergonomique et ben pour moi franchement
ça ne pose pas de problème particulier a
contrario les menus panasonic pour moi
me paraissent totalement opaque j'ai
vraiment énormément de mal à m'y
retrouver
ça veut pas dire que sony a une
meilleure ergonomie cabanac cannon que
nikon ça veut juste dire que dans ma
logique il ya des menus qui sont plus
simples que d'autres parce que j'ai une
logique à moi et que chacun a sa logique
pareil par exemple pour pour moi qui ai
pas forcément des grandes mains mais les
boîtiers sony mon petit doigt passe
toujours en dessous du boîtier parce que
le grip est pas foutu exactement comme
ma main devrait l'être par contre pour
quelqu'un qui a des plus petites mains
ce problème se posera pas donc on peut
pas vraiment dire qu'en termes
d'ergonomie est vraiment un gagnant sur
toutes ces caméras qui sont sortis en
2001 le plus que l'ergonomie et ben
c'est hyper subjectif ça va dépendre de
chacun on est tous différents un autre
point qui va vous aider à définir quelle
est la meilleure caméra pour
c'est la discipline que vous pratiquez
parce qu'on a souvent de tendance et ça
je le vois beaucoup en commentaire à
oublier que dans la vidéo il ya tout un
tas de sous registre quand on fait de la
vidéo on peut faire de l'événementiel on
peut faire du mariage on peut faire de
la fiction on peut faire du youtube ou
juste de la vidéo de vacances et j'en
oublie plein 1 mais il n'y a pas qu'une
seule discipline et certaines caméras
sont principalement faite pour une ou
plusieurs disciplines en particulier bah
oui parce que les professionnels
généralement ils ont une spécialité et
ils ont besoin d'un outil qui va avec
on va reprendre une autre alain caugy ça
me viendrait pas à l'idée d'aller dire à
un cycliste que le meilleur outil pour
lui pour faire du sport c'est une paire
de crampons analogie de merde mais voyez
l'idée tout comme on va pas à les
utiliser une raide qui est une caméra de
cinéma pour aller filmer ses vacances à
pornic
voilà c'est n'aurait aucun sens ça peut
se faire à faire du cyclisme avec du
crampon aussi mais eux
est ce que c'est vraiment ça aura une
grande utilité donc dans toutes ces
caméras qui sont sortis la question à se
poser c'est est-ce que ces caméras sont
destinés à un public particulier ce
qu'elles ont un objectif une cible en
particulier
et là encore à mon sens il n'y a pas
vraiment de gagnant parce qu'elles ont
toutes leur spécificité elles ont toutes
leur plus est leur moins et c'est encore
une fois en fonction de l'utilisateur
qui va falloir déterminer laquelle se
prête le plus à notre utilisation
s'il ya un point où on va pouvoir
peut-être trouver un gagnant c'est le
budget est ce qu'il ya un meilleur
rapport qualité prix sur une caméra mais
là encore c'est pareil ça n'existe pas
une caméra à 400 euros qui auraient les
mêmes fonctionnalités qu'une caméra à
4000 euros le prix des caméras ça va de
pas grand-chose à sommes astronomiques
et là encore une raison c'est que
généralement plus c'est cher plus il ya
de fonctionnalités spécifiques à cette
caméra et au type de prestation qu'on va
réaliser donc le choix d'une caméra et
ça c'est quelque chose que je vous dis
souvent sur un stack en vous me demandez
quelle caméra choisir n'oubliez pas de
me donner votre budget et si vous n'avez
pas d'idée de budget il faut absolument
en trouver un
parce que quelle est la meilleure caméra
pour moi si je fais du mariage à sa
dépendance ça dépend si
vous avez un budget 2000 euros ou si
vous avez un budget de dix mille euros
on va pouvoir trouver des choses et des
accessoires dans tous les budgets
mais forcément n'aura pas la même chose
donc le budget aussi c'est quelque chose
de primordial pour reprendre une autre
analogie puisque j'aime beaucoup les
analogies
imaginons que vous intéressiez à la
cuisine selon si vous êtes chef étoilé
dans un grand restaurant ou si vous
faites des gâteaux le dimanche après
midi là aussi bien sûr vous allez
pouvoir acheter un four à 2000 euros
pour faire un 4/4 ça va marcher mais
est-ce que c'est pertinent
encore une fois m voilà c'est pas que ça
marche pas c est ce que ça a un sens est
malheureusement toujours ben là aussi il
n'y a pas de gagnant parce que ben des
caméras très cher propose des choses que
des caméras peu cher ne propose pas mais
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin et est-ce
que ça s'y prête
là encore on va y arriver on va y
arriver on va trouver bien vous allez me
dire j'étais censé parler de la
meilleure caméra de 2020 et ben oui je
j'en parle tout de suite là maintenant
la meilleure caméra de 2020 c'est pas
forcément une marque un modèle en
particulier
je m'explique les débats sur les marques
de caméras ça me fait vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup rigolé j'arrive pas à
comprendre en fait dans les commentaires
des vidéos quand je parle d'une caméra
tous les gens qui disent ouais mais
telle marque ils se foutent de la gueule
du monde et machin ça c'est vachement
mieux et tout et puis il ya ça qui est
sorti et machins et là je me dis que
c'est important de connaître le matériel
de connaître son fonctionnement est de
savoir les fiches techniques c'est
vraiment très important pour savoir de
quoi on a besoin maintenant est ce qu'il
ya une marque qui fait quelque chose de
beaucoup mieux que les autres
aujourd'hui je pense pas toutes les
caméras que vous allez pouvoir acheter
aujourd'hui la qui sortent actuellement
sont de très très bonne caméra toutes
sans exception elles font toutes deux
superbes images il ya dix ans on aurait
rêvé d'avoir la moindre caméra comme ça
il fallait compter des dizaines de
milliers d'euros pour avoir le moindre
rendu un peu similaire à ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui à des appareils photos vous
quand même un peu fou il se bat pour une
marque en fait c'est quelque chose que
je comprends pas en fait ça me fait
beaucoup rire
je me dis c'est un peu comme si il y
avait des peintres par exemple un
peintre artiste un peintre en bâtiment
qui se foutaient sur la gueule parce que
non telle marque de pinceau c'est quand
même vachement mieux que tel autre
marque est ce qu'on avait déjà vu un
musicien recevoir un prix pour une
chanson ou un album et dire je remercie
la marque de mon piano parce que ça
aurait était impossible pour moi de
composer cet album sans ce piano la
spécifiquement de cette marche les
créateurs utilisent les outils qui leur
semble plus adaptée mais ça reste des
outils et selon les créateurs ya pas une
marque y'a pas un outil qui va être le
meilleur par rapport à tous les autres
donc la meilleure caméra c'est la
meilleure caméra pour vous et comment on
la trouve ça je vais vous expliquer à
mon avis comment il faut faire la
meilleure façon
regardez des tests en ligne tout c'est
vachement bien surtout de croiser les
différents avis parce que le gros
avantage internet c'est qu'on peut avoir
plein d'avis différents et ça va
permettre un petit peu de se faire sa
propre opinion mais le plus important à
mon sens c'est d'essayer ces caméras
c'est d'aller soit vous rapprocher de
quelqu'un que vous connaissez qu'il a pu
lui demander tiens je peux venir avec
toi et l'essayer voir un petit peu
comment ça fonctionne que tu m'en parle
un petit peu comment tu utilises vous
pouvez également aller dans un magasin
de photos tout simplement et puis
demander à essayer les appareils la
plupart des magasins proposent de vous
les et les prêter ou même pourquoi pas
quitte à mettre un petit billet en plus
pour être sûre à les louer
ce matériel et puis voir par vous même
si ça vous convient puis si vous
commandez en ligne vous avez un délai de
rétractation donc vous pouvez très bien
commander si vous avez un doute vous
tester si jamais vraiment ça vous
convient pas vous dit mince je me suis
trompé
vous renvoyez ya rien d'extraordinaire
là dedans et ça va vous permettre de
voir par vous même parce que c'est à mon
avis la seule façon efficace de définir
quelle est la meilleure caméra 2020 ou
de tous les temps et bien c'est tout
simplement que vous l'essayez que vous
voyez par vous même
moi j'aimerais quand même bien arrêter
de lire des foutage de gueule sur les
réseaux sociaux sur telle ou telle
marque ou même pire sur telle ou telle
personne parce qu'elle utilise une
marque c'est complètement ridicule si
vous kiffez cannon continue et qui fait
cannon et éclatez vous avec votre canne
ainsi l'outil pesos non utilisés du sont
ici vous kiffez nikon utiliser nikon si
vous kiffez panne à utiliser pana bref
faites vous plaisir on est là pour créer
on n'est pas là pour se taper dessus
parce qu'on a choisi une marque
cc c'est complètement surréaliste
en fait je trouve comme débats et bien
sûr la meilleure chose à faire là tout
de suite c'est de mettre le coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo de
rester curieux les amis que moi je vous
dis à très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo avait pas venir celle-là vous
attendiez la fiche de spec c'est tout
machin mais non c'est pas le genre de la
maison